I'm Skillet baby check me out on the
Boolean Kev podcast huh
bootleg cat podcast special guests in
here representing the d man my guy skill
a baby what is it it's your first time
on the show by yourself for sure you
were on last time with the
with Sada and that was a very
entertaining colorful conversation oh
crazy we had it's a lot of a lot of a
lot of talk and you were just in the
corner like who the [ __ ] are these old
ass men
well welcome man it's good to see you
um
you've gotten a lot more icier since the
last time I saw you
explain the uh tent with the Christmas
tree necklace what's going on here
yeah my friends we came up with
something we was in high school called
the end Camp so that's where the tent
from so is this like your crew your
label or it's my label am I I got a
label called we eat the most
and that's what my friends came up with
uh I ain't coming with that my friends
did I just wanna
I love my friends so [ __ ] I just wanna
if I can push the movement I'll push it
for real right that's dope man
um you've had a pretty active year in
terms of just like tons of Music being
dropped I know like everyone and their
mom's trying to sign you are you still
independent no I'm starting to guessing
through endoscope how long ago did the
uh Gathering thing happen like a month
ago well congratulations appreciate you
shout out to Geffen I know some good
Folks at Geffen well actually they just
left so they're not there anymore as of
like a week ago but shout out to Geffen
what made you go with Geffen
um it was more family oriented I know a
lot of people over there right and then
I know they threw Interscope I know a
lot of people is with Interscope yeah
like Gaffin has had some uh some some
success stories like uh dark [ __ ] got
uprooted or got Upstream today Rod wave
when Alamo was over there that's dope
man the whole CMG over there at
Interscope yeah so there's the effort
and stuff so they even gotten people
like 50 Cent and ice cubes and stuff
like that at Interscope still so well
not interscopes you know Interscope
that's where Eminem's at that's where
Kendrick well Kendrick was
and they yeah he's still kind of I was
like Hey Oh you know guessing through
endoscopes yeah I just felt like it was
a good move for me how crazy was like
the bidding war because was everybody in
Detroit is getting signed right now uh
so I know that like being one of the
hottest artists in the city you had to
have had maybe like your pick of the
litter in terms of like where you could
have went right yeah how crazy did I get
it was crazy it got so crazy to the
point where we got into arguments with
people like like people I ain't even
know like labels and stuff like that
like I had labels arguing like they they
did like the big one was crazy it
started at a number then it went up and
they went up like it's like an auction
for real I ain't never been a part of it
so I just sat back
but like my team like they was in
arguments and stuff like that
it's crazy I know you're a big sports
fan and it kind of feel like the closest
thing to like being a free agent and
being like recruited like you know we
were thinking like it was really like
draft like not even free agent it was
like me being in the draft I'm like oh
my God where I'm gonna go right like you
know it's just like because sometimes
you know how like it really was like the
college thing like
because I at a point I committed to
something and then I'm like do I really
like do I want to go there or do like am
I wrong but I don't know these people at
this point so I committed to these
people but I ain't it's not contractual
yet so it's like
my loyalty and me be like I committed to
something because that's how I was
raised like if I commit to some I'm
supposed to do that but business-wise if
it don't make sense I shouldn't do it so
it's like so did you commit to somebody
and then end up going to somewhere else
I end up I ended up committing to
somebody then
I end up
they was playing like they was they was
like the contracts weren't ready and all
this stuff I don't think there's plenty
just you know how the business stuff the
lawyer worked but I didn't know about
this at this point like I got lawyers
and stuff I never had like entertainment
lawyers and stuff so it's like contracts
weren't ready then somebody else came
and offered more and and pull it up on
me and made me feel like you know how
people be like they'll pull up on you
and make you want to change your mind
even though he pulled upon you was it
Gavin
gefin had already pulled up on me it was
really uh Jeff from uh he is over at
where he was at he's at Columbia now but
he was somewhere else so you just had
everyone yeah coming to Detroit
they had to come see you I went to go
see people it was just like it was crazy
for real for real at a point in time it
was crazy to a point where I just
seeing the label didn't I'd be like damn
I want to go there did another label
like United Masters or something a DME
or Atlantic or something like that and
he just it was crazy so obviously
shout out to SATA who's somebody who
helped you know you come up in the game
was was there any other artists like
because there's some artists with big
labels right you mentioned TMG there's
MMG there's I mean you can go on and on
did any other artists like try to come
in and like become a part of your
situation
no because I'm not really a I'm a people
person but I don't really let I don't
deal with like I deal well with people
but I don't really I'm standoffish right
so like
I like hanging with like the managers
and CEOs I don't really like hangover
artists because I feel like I can do the
same thing as you for real so and it's
like there's a few of those artists
though that are like you know like if I
be around them yeah it'd be like that
but it's like I already got my own money
I don't really need your money and then
just be like
everything on the internet or everybody
I stay away from artists because I've
been disappointed before like not by
like nobody that you see me with but
I've been disappointed with like meeting
people and they not like the same as I
thought there was going to be like
growing up like of course if I listen to
your music I damn there don't want to be
around you because
if I think like you're not like like I
don't it don't be my favorite side it'd
be like more of them [ __ ] like yeah it'd
be like you grew up being a fan of
somebody you meet them and they're not a
good person yeah like if you're not a
good person when I meet you or you like
an [ __ ]
and then be like that'd be like
bothering me so I try to stay away from
people the artists who's somebody that
you have met that you were a fan of that
did not disappoint you Chris Brown Chris
Brown G herbo they were like real
genuine G herbo's the best they like it
was real genuine like
Chris Brown like you would think Chris
Brown and forget your name the next time
you see you he still know your name like
and like right this before anybody knew
I was trying to do music like I met
Chris Brown I was with shot him right
like and Chris Brown hop on that like
I [ __ ] with duck I ain't gonna lie did
you go with Sada when he met jelly roll
in in uh Detroit
jelly Rose my boy he does like country
and it was the most random [ __ ] ever I
like opened my story and I see Sada baby
like backstage with jelly roll I'm like
this is [ __ ] this is great it's like
the best of two different worlds coming
together I didn't know if you were with
him or not but
um
so obviously I want to get your take
because
uh there are a few cities in hip-hop
right now that I feel like are very
instrumental to the culture
um
Detroit's always had a presence in
hip-hop
but it's always been kind of like
it's like Eminem or Big Sean or you know
even guys like back in the day like slum
Village but like the street side was
always kind of like more underground
which is crazy you know what I'm saying
but nowadays man you guys are kind of at
the Forefront of a lot of influence and
a lot of culture and every uh label is
swooping everybody up from the city
um
at like a Pace that I haven't seen
um and you know obviously guys like Sada
baby guys like T Grizzly all these guys
kind of kicked the door down for the
generation that's popping right now what
do you think it is about Detroit where
like everyone's finally kind of paying
attention and given like the Cur like
the respect that y'all deserve in terms
of the industry I think after T Grizzly
did it if uh it put a lot of people in
rooms that we couldn't get in like and
then people started just networking with
other people it's like on her um Detroit
get a lot of recognition because like
everybody be in the streets so like
right after T Grizzly got out there like
other people was in rooms with other
artists that's also in the streets I
feel like so they got to doing music and
hanging out with each other and doing
stuff like that so I just felt like that
was big that after cider did it it just
kicked some more doors down then like a
Snowball Effect Doug did it yeah yeah
duh I actually think like
I think um
T was the first to do it
Sada did it the
um solid did it like on the talent wise
Sada did it the best T was the first and
I think Doug just went to Fairless like
yeah as far as like networking and
having platinum records and stuff like
that not not his baby face
Babyface Ray he doing his things killing
it
um Vaso it's been dope to see his career
um baby money Tay like everybody
networking with people and that's right
I love to see that part of Goldie James
staple for years he's been in staple for
a long time especially in that like very
my favorite type of hip-hop yeah I think
he don't get enough flowers sometimes
sure for sure like Bo Jackson's so crazy
it's great shout out to shout out to
bully hey what up y'all we gotta
interrupt the interview real quick to
tell you about our family and my bookie
that's right football season is
happening uh World Cup finals coming up
who do you got I don't know I'm gonna go
with Messi in Argentina I'm gonna Hammer
that bad boy uh there's so much ways to
get money off of sports and you could do
it with my bookie man let me tell you if
you sign up in my bookie right now with
that promo code bootleg you're gonna get
your first deposit matched up to a
thousand dollars that's right free money
to gamble with so if you put a thousand
in your account for the first deposit
you use that promo code bootleg they're
gonna give you another thousand to throw
down we got NFL playoffs coming up end
of the season happening a lot of ways to
get this money you can start betting on
the NFL MVP I'm telling you Jalen hurts
is winning that thing so put all the
money you got
that you can afford to lose on Jalen
hurts don't listen to me though I'm not
an expert uh with that being said though
I have been doing really good on my
bookie this year you can do the same
thing man so many ways to make money NBA
NFL World Cup whatever it is college
football
Etc go to my bookie right now sign up
with that promo code bootleg and you
will get your first deposit matched up
to a thousand dollars man all right go
do that shout out to my bookie let's get
back to the interview
um you recently got shot yeah
are you I mean you're fine you're here
I'm good
um but uh
I mean that has to be a traumatic thing
to to get through
it wasn't really like traumatic to me
though like did you I mean I don't want
you to get into the specifics of the
situation but like
is that something that happens and you
become like a different person after
that or do you move differently after
something like that happens it changed
me but it ain't it ain't it changed me
for the better like
um
I know what I'd be doing when I get into
stuff so I know what be going on like I
know the possibility this [ __ ] that that
come behind my actions and even my
reactions so
but I wouldn't say like I got shot
I damn it wouldn't do nothing different
so it ain't changed me on the situation
so I just changed me to move better for
real well I feel like too like uh at a
lot of the younger artists that I speak
with man you're like one of the more
like you're a very smart kid man like
when I interviewed you
um with Sada baby I felt like you were
the adult in the interview
and me and Sarah baby were like the uh
the old creepy uncles and you're like I
don't do drugs y'all are talking about
gas station dick pills what the [ __ ] are
y'all dudes on but like in terms of just
like your attitude I was like yo like
you really got
the type of attitude that will like
result in longevity as long as you could
just try to stay out the way of that
other [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
I really don't I don't normally get into
stuff like that it just sometimes you're
just at the wrong place at the wrong
time of course you feel me something
you're just inevitable it's got some
stuff is like unavoidable right yeah
like you can't uh you can't be like
cooped up in the [ __ ] house all day
for sure like stuff just like you have
lightning strikes places yeah like
that's why like you can't
you get like you got to be strong-minded
about stuff like you gotta know like
accept what come with what you're doing
right
was uh was just a feeling like like was
it the craziest pain you've ever been
through in terms of just physical right
I ain't feel when I got shot I ain't
even full
all right yeah and that's I walked off
if you didn't feel it I saw adrenaline's
pumping I'm sure I don't know I just
walked off and [ __ ]
that just happened like I ain't it ain't
the swordness after getting shot is
really what hurt like right like the
after effects are like recovering and
like the big ass bruise I had on my ass
because it went through my stomach and
came on my ass don't nobody even know
that
so the Bullet came out of your butt
cheek I swear to God
did you have to sit on a donut
no not for real I broke my tailbone not
the same thing when I was like it's 50
Ways straight through I ain't hitting no
bones or hitting us so just straight
booty meat
[Laughter]
to be a rough go for like taking a [ __ ]
for a few months huh
put all the [ __ ] weight on the like
the cheek that didn't get shot
[Laughter]
like you ever feel like you play sports
and like feel on hardwood yeah oh yeah
it felt like that like but I was
laughing and [ __ ] my mama was mad
because I got out the hospital the same
night it was laughing and [ __ ] I played
I played too much for real yeah you got
a lot of talent man you got a lot of uh
you got a bright future ahead of you bro
you gotta just you know try to avoid all
that all those situations I'm a real man
or young man though I want people to
really know that though I agree I'm a
real manner I don't look for trouble I'm
not going to get in trouble none of that
I'm I'm a good person yeah and you have
braces you're like a child for sure
um so now that you're with Geffen
because you're kind of like uh you're
the type of artist that
so far I feel like kind of
is a perfect like you're you being
independent matches your output because
you have a high output of Music
um
how's the adjustment going to be being
with a major label are you still going
to be able to drop as frequently as you
want or is it going to be like like oh
really cool with like the president of
my label and stuff like that so I'm cool
with everybody in my label I got a good
relationship so if they say something
don't make sense I know it probably
don't make sense because they've been
there before so I don't really you know
I don't
oh my mind just hold nothing doing
things the right way that's what I got
with the label it wasn't really about no
money it's really about being in the
rooms and taking my stuff to the next
level so if that's what I got to do to
take myself to the next level that's
what I just got to do like have you put
any music out since signing there's the
tweaking record through them or
that somebody leaked my song that's not
even your song you didn't put that out
though no so someone just uploaded that
on distro kids
that's really a snippet like I'll be
uploading my music sometimes like screen
recording it and somebody screen
recording my page and uploaded it under
your profile yeah like they got that off
my story what the [ __ ] they got that off
my story or screen recorded it and
uploaded I just told my labor like I
gotta tell you I gotta take that down
Somebody went out of the way made an art
for it and everything for sure that
shit's crazy that's like the new bootleg
[ __ ] like imagine like signing up for a
distro kit account and uploading someone
else's [ __ ]
they wouldn't really I wasn't never
gonna put that out for real
that's just something I went to the
studio and had some on my chest and I
want the rap about it but that's not I
wasn't gonna put that out damn you're
getting bootlegged on Spotify now for
sure that's wild they gotta take that
down though yeah damn what's so okay so
uh your your major label debut or slash
project and how I didn't know you were
sitting on probably hundreds of songs
do you know what that's looking like yet
my EP come out Thursday night Friday
morning so the ep's already put together
what's it called we eat the most which
is obviously you know it's uh on your
chain there pushing a brand yeah sure
how many songs
what is eight one
yeah who's on the album or EP whatever
we're calling it me just you no no
features I'm saving my my features for
another time I Really they want
if the team like wanted me to put
something up so I let them pick the
songs and put something out so they can
they said they want to defeat the fans
so
you know video shot video shot nice
three or four of them shot
what's the best Coney in uh in Detroit
huh you see the zorbers or uh
L George's absorbers on the east side
six miles and gangster
um and you know George is on the west
side on like Greenfield and Six Mile hmm
what makes a like a good Coney place is
it like does the hot dog have to be fire
or does it like they got oh there's so
much stuff on the menu right I only get
Connie dogs sometimes it's really like
anywhere in Detroit is to cook because
the people be cooking the same thing and
it tastes different like you feel me
like it's just really to cook because
sometimes I go to Coney and get some
pancakes or french toast and it could be
the middle of the night but sometimes I
go get corned beef and
chili cheese fries or winged you ain't
dealing with chili cheese fries it's
always to cook because somebody might
burn your wingdings or you drink like
wing dings yeah what's that it's like
small chickens it's small chicken wings
like a baby like a baby chicken like
baby chicken wings like that dings
that's wild like they cut the little
flat part off the wings like that and
it's just the thing
the wind gangs I've heard of that hey
wing dings I just know that what was the
name of that burger place you brought us
Burgers from or the [ __ ] Patties or
this fat one
it was you got them big babies it was
the juiciest most gigantic
[ __ ] hamburger for sure food exchange
they come the big baby come with corned
beef and a burger oh my God it was just
a lot going on uh-huh it was gas though
it was amazing it was amazing great I
like the food out there no I I really
only like food at home for real I was
eating at the uh you know where they got
terrible food it's at MGM Detroit all
the food court choices there are
terrible oh that's the casino though I'm
aware it was like but I was just like
there's nothing you gotta go to the
neighborhoods like oh I was there or the
strip clubs like went to the strip club
too
I did not go to um
trust is that it truth truth didn't go
there I heard that was good where you go
to Pantheon
no we went to uh Ace of Spades with
mozzie and then uh
Street Lord wants sent it to some white
club uh that was terrible Coliseum maybe
oh my God it was like a bunch of Juggalo
women were dancing
okay you wanted to see the black girls I
just I don't [ __ ] with white women bro
but you know what it was was like it was
like our first night in town and like he
couldn't come out with us Heather's sick
and so I I felt like
he wanted to send us somewhere he
thought we'd be safe so he sent us there
and then we walked in and I was like he
wanted to see the big booty black girls
with the bbas the Spades was was great
I'm hit great talent they had ass
little Blade's birthday party in there
and um mozzie was performing
payroll Giovanni was there it was a good
time I love Detroit man it was very
chill I liked it it was [ __ ] and
that'd be it ain't like everybody make
it seem like it's really fun I [ __ ]
loved it I was like I tell everybody I'm
like yo Detroit's fire everybody was
super nice I also had zero clue that you
guys are like you could throw a rock and
hit Canada
do you go to Canada sometimes no
just why not it's like you could just
drive over there I'm back I just got my
passport and I just stopped being a
felon but I ain't stopped being a
failure I just got off felony probation
so I like how you said that I just
stopped being a felon by the way
congratulations I'm glad you made that
life choice but uh do you have because
it's hard to get into Canada if you have
a felony right yeah but could you get
are you fine though I'm trying to get
cool with Drake I mean I'm sure that'll
happen right he hasn't latched on to a
Detroit artist yet
he'll latch on to somebody my cousin
here Detroit artist he just took a
picture with Drake
um
that's and a little baby took the
picture I'm like that's fire I am
surprised that Drake hasn't um
really dug in with like a Detroit artist
yet it feels like the type of thing he
would do you know he brought um cash
doll out one time I mean
how long ago was that like 2017 or 18 19
maybe probably something like that you
probably remember it yeah he could show
by her out Castro's a legend Dej loves a
legend shout out to today's what up it's
bootleg cat man we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our good
Folks at Bluetooth that's right fellas
if you're dealing with a little erectile
dysfunction yeah dick's not working like
it should be bud don't trip bluetooth's
got you yeah maybe you're a little
stressed out
at home at work little performance
anxiety yeah well look don't trip much
you will make your dick rock hard oh
yeah that's right super hard uh all you
got to do is go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg that's boat leg for
you non-spelling [ __ ] out there use
that promo code they're gonna send you a
month's supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth you ask let me tell
you the same active ingredient as Viagra
Ana Cialis minus the awkward doctor's
visits nobody wants to go to a [ __ ]
doctor's office sit in line you're
reading an old-time Magazine from three
years ago waiting for your name to get
called so go in there and tell your
doctor your dick ain't working like it
should be
nobody wants to do that nope but on
bluetooth.com it's all online they send
it right to your door discrete packaging
in a chewable form
look what are we talking about use the
promo code bootleg get a month for free
all you do is pay five dollars in
shipping right and they just did their
Bluetooth mint chewable the same active
ingredient as Levitra
which is a little extra hitter you know
what I mean so fellas ladies Etc if you
need to you know get your dick right go
to bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and try it for a month for free
free
what are we doing we're getting back to
the interview that's what we're doing
what about uh for you like are you
listening to
like if if I got in your car outside of
your [ __ ] your crew [ __ ] what is on your
Spotify or apple music like what are you
listening to as far as Detroit artist no
anybody I tell you I'm about to tell you
right now
I got some [ __ ] on here
artists I got a deal Alicia Keys The
All-American Rejects All-Star JR this is
my a through b All-American Rejects huh
Babyface Ray baby money javar Ben King
big Boogie I got everything black
youngster
I got glow really
Drake and 21 Savage Drew Hill Kodak
Black Little Baby Jay-Z g herbo a little
bit I got everything let me see let me
see I'm gonna see what's the most random
[ __ ] I can find on your planet let's see
I got [ __ ] on there
Anita Baker my favorite artist
hey shout out to Drew Hill throwing that
Drew Hill get get you know shout out to
Boston Richie all right
Rod wave you listening to yourself you
as you should
some Mary J my life
I was hoping to see like Pantera or corn
or some random [ __ ] I got um
are you [ __ ] with LA Wale de Sensei
um
some black streets of SW your r b head I
got Halsey on my [ __ ] all type of [ __ ]
you know halsey's black no
she's uh her dad's black I didn't know
that if you see her she's very but her
mom's white yeah but if you like she
also looks like a like a white girl for
real you know but I guess she's mixed
race yeah so your daddy Gene is the
dominant gene
um
um so what are you trying to say I feel
like you kicking her out the white
community no no no
I don't know what that means I don't
give a [ __ ] bro
I'm not I'm not [ __ ] rep I'm not the
[ __ ] captain of white people I'm not
the one picking the [ __ ] I'm just
saying like that's what you said she
looked white but she's black she looks
white but she's like yeah I'm just
saying is she also what yeah she's both
you could be both right
yeah technically but you basically told
us that she was black like she looked
white but she black that's what you said
are you trying to what kind of awkward
conundrum are you trying to put me in
right now
Jesus Christ this [ __ ] guy how you
feeling about the Pistons man a lot of
great young pieces Kate Cunningham's out
for the year it looks like that hurt my
heart yeah man he was balling too but
you guys got some [ __ ] you guys had a
great draft Yeah but that's hard and I'm
going on traffic we ain't got one
I'm gonna try if you go out that's like
I mean how you feel though I mean the
future I like the Pistons
I think we just need a great big and
then somebody that's gonna because my
man is Isaiah Stewart that's my homeboy
like he had really beat somebody up I
mean I feel like we need like LeBron
right yeah but I think we need somebody
that like that like people fear like
Draymond Green or something like that so
he's your friend but you're saying
people don't fear Him much I'm not
saying that people that people don't
fear him it's just that like they know
like
he really he ain't nothing to play with
I don't think they feel like that so
he's like you've done his Haslam just
like have him come in and like chill
though like he chill like he only gonna
get on that if you like he don't like
you like he only gonna get on that and
like follow you hardest but I need
somebody like and he gonna do it with a
mad face like he gonna let you know he
don't [ __ ] with you right I need
somebody like Draymond Green that's just
doing a whole [ __ ] for no reason on the
Pistons like like Patrick Beverly yeah
like I'm just doing whole [ __ ] like yeah
I'm just doing this like I'm with
whatever with a smile on my face like
I'm gonna kick you on your [ __ ] but I
need that on the Pistons like the bad
boys he's a beast though man Ivy and
Kate Cunningham together that could be
the I mean Sadiq basic uh what's the
name of the the big man y'all drafted
the other guy you guys had two picks
this what's his name are you talking
about um from Iowa this year guys this
year is Jane Ivy and Dennis Jalen Duran
you're talking about dog Duran Duran's
nice They're ran nice I wish you guys
would have [ __ ] traded somebody good
for Tommy I'm sorry no for my sons
I thought ayton was going to the Pistons
uh I think I like DeAndre Aiden he just
not tough enough for me like I just want
him to dunk and no no offense
to him I'm a sense fan [ __ ]
dunked the ball no offense to DeAndre
can you do it no way scream at somebody
there's no way that Shaq letting Patrick
Beverly put push him down like um you
feel me I don't just like I don't like
that I don't like that like he was
supposed to Big Show choke slam for that
big show that's the type of basketball I
like though I like rough rugged
basketball like jail boy do you remember
when Shaq and you don't remember but
there was a fight
when you were probably in I'm not even
you might not have existed yet Shaquille
O'Neal and Charles Barkley got into it
when Shaq was Irwin Barkley was on the
rockets and Charles Barkley body slammed
Shaquille O'Neal he's [ __ ] it's on
YouTube yeah I I watched that on the
highlights before and then I heard Shaq
talking to Charles Barkley like I think
that's that's why I check always on
Charles Barkley ass because he's
Knuckles when I was a kid because I was
I lived in Phoenix I'm from Phoenix uh
he [ __ ] was downtown and he got into
a fight with a guy and he threw him
through the glass window at a bar that's
a big man though like Charles Barker I
mean he's he's the round Mound he's like
six four six five damn Charles Barkley
remind me of Muhammad Ali or something
like they used to call him the round
mound of rebound
a round guy
do they the Pistons are they listening
to your [ __ ] are you are they tapping in
or like you know what I mean okay come
here follow me Isaiah Stewart he [ __ ]
with me what's up with your guy miles
Bridges how are we getting him back in
the league the last time we can't you
guys came up here he actually he bought
the I think
somebody told me that he about to get
signed again like I'll be with him a lot
that's my brother but I support anything
you do and he's like he actually I know
that's your guys's actual friend yeah do
you guys ever pull him to the side and
say Hey look
you like I talked to you got a lot of
money in the air that you're I don't
want to be a rapper that bad I talked to
bro but I don't try to drill something
into them that I that he already know
that's just like if I [ __ ] up I already
know he knows he [ __ ] up he know he
[ __ ] up right so when I see him like
that's with anybody though if I see you
doing something now I feel like is wrong
I might I'm probably gonna tell you so I
I always had conversations with bro but
at the end of the day I know I'm young
he young people make mistakes is he
still trying to to rap to pursue the rap
thing
uh we actually be in the studio together
bro I know I'm saying like I'm saying is
that still like a priority for him or
it's like I was in a studio with him
like two days ago oh he's a great rapper
I was in the studio bro we just made a
song like two days ago yeah but like
I think I just hope the best I feel like
if the Piston Signum it's a problem
I didn't think I know where you're going
but the lockers I think I think I know
where you're going but like I mean you
have inside information let's make ESPN
right now ESPN yeah let's be on let's be
on uh let's be on part in the
interruption tomorrow you want me to
tell you where you're going where's he
going the NBA I mean I know that but
what is it the Lakers is it is it the I
mean it's not going to be the uh the
Hornets it's the team in the NBA for
real which conference the NBA give me a
conference that's all either the west or
the East either one yeah one or two
so it's the Lakers it's not the south
for the north conferences yeah well
those don't exist
I know you're going to the NBA for sure
he but actually
brother's about to do some Community
work that he already been doing but he's
about to be doing some extra Community
work and y'all should tap in with that
he's not community service community
service like community service like he's
about to continue doing what he's been
doing giving back to mothers in need and
stuff like that that's what people
should tap in with what he's doing but
not like he was forced to do community
service no he already been doing it all
right
well uh the rep comes out by the time
people watch this we'll probably drop
this on Monday so your [ __ ] drops next
Thursday right this Thursday no this
Thursday oh so by the time this comes
out what's today is Tuesday
so we'll probably drop this tomorrow or
Thursday we'll drop it Thursday so
Thursday night
that's hard tonight the shit's dropping
flat out go run that EP up and then the
album is on the way
and anything else that you have going on
are you like uh
expanding your entrepreneurial footprint
into anything I'm trying to get
into real estate
um
I'm actually think I'll I'll be
contemplating it I'm thinking about
signing somebody uh
signing an artist under your imprint
[Music]
I'm just doing
right now I'm trying to I'll be getting
with a lot of investors to
work on I know like I don't have to make
a big ass investment I just want to make
a bunch of little smaller Investments
that just stay away from the crypto man
no I'm not doing crypto yeah I'm not
really like
um what's that called real estate's fire
yeah I'm not really like with the um
like the like online stuff I don't
really like that type of stuff like that
type of stuff you're not you're not
you're not a big fan of the internet
yeah I'm not really with that especially
making money like you're still buying
you're still buying magazines and DVDs
no
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
hard Dean that's right hard Dean Las
Vegas the craziest dispensary in the
world the number one dispensary in the
United States let alone in Las Vegas all
right maybe you're hitting Vegas with
your friends your girlfriends whatever
maybe it's a bachelor party whatever's
going on you're going to go watch the
Raiders suck [ __ ] whatever it is make
sure you pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas
tell them I sent you they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
I've ever seen in my [ __ ] life the
pre-rolls the cartridges the Edibles the
flower all top notch all the best the
bud tenders are so friendly it smells
great it smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
see I sniff that and I just think of Las
Vegas and picking up some amazing weed
all right so go follow them right now
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot him a
follow get all the details you need you
can get you some of this fly ass Harding
merch at hardinglasvegas.com shout out
to our family in Vegas I'm excited too
because coming up we're going to be
doing our very first podcast from Jardin
in Vegas with young gravy oh yeah it's
going down all right let's get back to
the interview how about books though
what's your favorite book
um nighttime what's it called night John
uh-huh what's that about it's about a
slave that taught some other slaves how
to read oh let's go then they ran away
got away but he had to he got caught
they chopped his hand off
I think more people should read more men
my favorite author is David bardachi
I don't know who that is but I'm also
not a huge um
I'm not a huge book guy only like like I
know some like I like more like
self-help books or like books about like
uh like I like autobiographies and stuff
like that like if it's
about I [ __ ] read I don't know how
many Michael Jordan books in my life but
oh that's your favorite player
as a child yes but as a grown man I
could acknowledge that LeBron James is
the goat no I thought it was Kobe though
no no you and I we talked about this
last time because you came up here
because you've clearly said it was Kobe
now you're switching it because we on
camera it's crazy I would never he
switched me because we are on camera
never in my life when I say Kobe's to go
he's switching up he clearly I have him
up there with Jordan right they're up
there together that's let me just talk
about that picture no I love it I love
Kobe oh my God he's not LeBron I can't
believe you doing this to his kid Kobe
ain't even Tim Duncan
cut the camera Kobe's like seventh all
time number seven
or eight you talk about it man there's
like 12 time on defense
81 points in the game
broke his arm shot with the ball with
the left hand held his left hand three
from the corner
what you thinking
okay listen Dunk Contest winner MVP
listen he doesn't ring a bill can you
five remind me what happened remind me
what happened when
Shaquille O'Neal left the Lakers she had
won two more championships no no no wait
wait a minute let me finish let me
finish
so Shaq left the Lakers right
now this is before Pau Gasol joined the
Lakers I'm asking this though there was
a few years there
where the Lakers were like the eight
seed and getting bounced in the first
round right because Kobe was it was just
Kobe this is uh during the 81-point era
there was no Pau Gasol yet
all right so that happens
couldn't get out of the first round by
himself unlike a guy like LeBron James
who got to the finals by himself and
didn't win but he got to the finals at
least he got out of the first round now
okay okay you get Pau Gasol you have
Andrew Bynum you have Lamar Odom you got
a team you get your other Rings cool
well what happens when
things kind of hit a wall
he takes that last contract Kobe Bryant
took that last contract and literally
just sank the Lakers for like five years
you you're talking about personal
matters no no I'm talking about Kobe
Bryant I'm talking about the LeBron era
when LeBron and no I'm not taking
nothing from LeBron because no no no
what happened what player let's talk
about LeBron's in year 20 right now
let's talk about LeBron for one second
conference was nothing he played against
Dwight Howard they like the Easter
Conference Finals he's playing against
Dwight Howard
let's talk about how Kobe got Sasha
Voyage ring lukewar and Jordan Farmer I
think oh and we can also talk about
Lamar Odom Andrew Bynum and yeah
yeah listen you can't bring up all these
random [ __ ] dudes when Shaq was also
on the team they wasn't on the team with
Shaq the farmer wasn't on the shack
teams probably former I don't believe I
don't remember that though but that
being said
Pau Gasol is an Alzheimer
one of the greatest powerful who did
something after they left Kobe
except Shaq Shaq got a ring who did
something except Shaq Jordan Clarkson's
been the Sixth Man of the Year
you tell about the end of Kobe career oh
so year 20 Kobe after he broke
everything on his body okay so what's
LeBron doing in year 20 19 18 what is he
doing he won a ring two years ago he's
losing a lot he won a [ __ ] ring two
years nobody but LeBron wanted to play
I love LeBron as a person but as a
player I'm a blind hater
well y'all disrespect Kobe everywhere I
go and this well look at the end of the
day Kobe Kobe could never put a shitty
team on his back and take him to the
finals what was the shitty team Andrew
Bynum Andrew Bynum was in the All-Star
Game
all NBA Center Pau Gasol when did they
when did Pau Gasol or Andrew Bynum do
anything after they left the song was a
beast before he was in L.A he was a
[ __ ] beast on the Grizzlies what are
you talking about how old were you when
all this was actually happening I was
young how old
how old I was young how old were you in
2005 2005 I think I was seven years old
yeah so what the [ __ ] do you even know
what you're talking about right now a
lot get off of YouTube I was playing my
sports
my eight-year-old son swears he knows
about everybody because he'd be watching
YouTube highlight Clips I was playing
sports
I really watched was the Pistons and the
Lakers so I know everything about Kobe
you can't really argue with me about
colbyisms and never enter conversations
like religion or politics Kobe I'm going
to bat for that man like y'all ain't
gonna keep disrespecting Kobe bro I
didn't disrespect him I just said he's
like 7 all the time never
what are you talking about how
how Kareem Abdul-Jabbar is better no
Magic Johnson no Tim Duncan what did
they do better they had more talent to
him Kareem Abdul did they have more
talent to him did they dribble better
shoot better did they pass better Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar did they dunk the ball back
National Championships in college NBA
rings League MVPs the all-time greatest
he's the number one scorer in NBA
history so he had the most indefensible
shot ever so the sky hook is
indefendable no one could if if he was
in a league right now nobody could
defend Kareem Abdul-Jabbar who's
blocking the sky hook I'm saying are you
going to the park to watch your Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar play over Kobe what is that
okay if that's the [ __ ] case then if
that's the [ __ ] case Skip to My Lou's
the greatest [ __ ] player of all time
because his N1 tapes were amazing no but
they traveling I love the professor Tui
they traveling Jason Williams from the
Kings had cute passes traveling Dublin
carrying we talk about scoring the
basketball playing defense doing a it
was more exciting to see Kobe go
windmill that [ __ ] on the 360. what
does that mean that doesn't mean that's
what we talk about no if that's the case
something exciting they're seeing the
Skyhook I want to see a [ __ ] do a 360
in the air and windmill Jam that [ __ ]
like he on NBA live like I want to see
that that's what I want to see I don't
want to see a Skyhook that's like that's
like this that's why the best players of
all time to you are the most exciting to
watch
yes hmm for sure so right now right now
John morant's the best player on the
phone for sure for short as my favorite
player in the NBA of course anybody will
tell you that he's going crazy it's
exciting to watch him we've already we
ladies and gentlemen this is Skillet
baby and we now know how he determines
who the greats are his talent his talent
if you can if you can give him a 10
minute YouTube compilation because
that's how he grew up watching
basketball because he was seven years
old when Kobe was good I want to see I
want to see Steph Curry shoot from half
court better than I want to see LeBron
run somebody over and lay the ball up
yes Skillet baby of course he loves
YouTube compilations of basketball
highlights no he did I really watched
this [ __ ] League
Pass wasn't a thing when he was a child
so he didn't really watch them unless
they were on NBC on Saturdays or TNT no
we had cable
hey we got to stop the interview to tell
you about our family at odd sucks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview so you got to watch TNT
for sure and ESPN all right yeah ABC
don't forget okay Sunday's ABC came on
so you're okay so Derrick Jones Jr is
also one of the greatest of all times
he's the best dunker in the world no
he's not the best dunk in the league
he's very high jumper he's the highest
jumper he's the highest jumper Zion got
more athleticism than him he's like a
BBW guy I'm talking about like John
Moran is the best dunker in the league
he's hot flying he's doing exciting
stuff he's turned around in the middle
of the area windmill in that [ __ ] Derek
Jones Jr is not doing that I think I
think Zion's the best in-game dunker
yeah for sure but then his job all right
I can't believe you hate no John Moran
and Coach oh no I love John Murray this
is crazy well no John Moran's my
favorite player to watch
right now but he's not the best
just because I like to watch him don't
make him better than what make you the
best I think Luke is the best player in
the league okay thank you and he's not
very exciting to watch because he's just
like he looks like me
you know it's exciting you know why
because he got real skill of course so
real skill matters that's a skill to
dunk the basketball and shoot the
basketball don't dribble the basketball
that's the skill so you're saying Luca
is the best like skill wise yes no the
best player right now if you're okay
you're the [ __ ] Luca for sure so
you're the uh GM of the Pistons you have
the number one pick at any player
fantasy draft in Luca Luke is your
number one pick yes okay
well at least we we agree you know okay
Luca you got
you got I'm getting Luke I had an
argument I'm excited about this I think
he he said because he's a real
basketball he feel like Dirk now whiskey
is better than Luca and I don't well
Dirk's 50. I mean like right now no I'm
talking about him all time hey I gotta
get that ring first man it's not about
ringing to me
Dirk was MVP Dirk beat the the heat in
2011. for sure but I feel like Luca can
do more
you're probably right
well look man Black Talent that's what I
do if you had to compare your rapping to
an NBA player's game
you're the what of the rap game you're
the who of the rap game are you the Luka
donkic of the rap game can you do
anything you can put 40 up at will on
the mic what are you doing
um John Morant you're the John Moran
exciting to it's exciting to hear me I'm
gonna do stuff that you think that
nobody should do like that's what I'm
gonna do
well at least you didn't say you were
the Robin Lopez of the rap game
because that would have been I feel like
I I just feel like I'm John Morant
because like I feel like it's exciting
to hear what I'm gonna say I might I
might lay the ball up I'm like do a
fancy layup I might come dunk it I might
just shoot I might floater it depends I
feel like I could do a lot of stuff
who do you know I ain't saying John
Morant
I ain't seeing John marant the best
player ever but I think he's Kobe
Michael Jordan type Kelly he could be he
could be but he can stay healthy he's
got to take care he's got to preserve
his body get into that paint sometimes
yeah he'd be kind of turning then it's
just hard being a high flyer for real
right it's bad on the knees well listen
man your new EP is out tonight
go uh run it up no features straight
solo appreciate you coming through we're
gonna have you rap too so there'll be a
separate YouTube video this guy showing
us why he's the John Moran of the rap
game let's go Skillet baby